hello we start with breaking news eight
children and a security guard have been
killed after a 14 year old boy opened
fire in a school classroom in the
Serbian Capital Belgrade
while our Europe correspondent Siobhan
Robbins joins us now from Berlin uh
Siobhan this is a shocking event just
tell us what we know about what happened
yes very tragic news coming from
Belgrade today as you say we know that
nine people in total are believed to
have been killed in this shooting at a
school in central Belgrade eight
children and one security are among the
dead another six children at least have
been injured and a teacher some of those
injuries are reported to be serious what
we know about what's happened so far
coming from the police and the
government is that around 8 40 local
time this morning the police arrived at
this school it's reported that this boy
who is believed to be around 14 years
old born in 2009 had entered the school
where he is believed to have been a
pupil and had opened fire injuring and
killing other classmates as well as this
teacher now we don't know why this
happened but what we do know from local
media is that police were filmed
removing the suspect effects from the
scene with his head covered and the
parents of other children had arrived by
this time extremely frightened to see
whether their children were okay now
this is a really rare situation to
happen in Serbia there aren't many mass
shootings in fact the last one was
around a decade ago when a war veteran
shot 13 people however experts have
raised concerns in the past about the
huge number of weapons which have been
discarded following the war in the 90s
so there is concern this is still an
active investigation but as I say the
suspect believed to be a teenage boy has
been detained
thank you very much for bringing us that
detail